كيف يبدو الوضع من غلاف غزه
نجوان نعم في هذه المناطق التي نقابل فيها
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه لا تتوقف
اصوات الانفجارات ولكن في نفس الوقت
هناك اللافت هو بان عمليات القصف قد
تراجعت وقد انخفضت بشكل ملحوظ في هذه
المناطق نشوان لا سما وانها المناطق التي
انطلقت منها العمليات البريه وا هذذه
الحرب عمليا بعمليات القصف المتواصله اي
سواء كان من الجو او من البر منذ السابع
من اكتوبر ولكن في الايام الاخيره الماضيه
بدا الجيش الاسرائيلي يسحب اعدادا من
قواته من داخل هذه المناطق و وبدا ايضا
يعيد انتشار هذه ال القوات وقد اعلن يوم
امس وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي بانه ايه في
هذه المناطق تحديدا انتقل الجيش
الاسرائيلي الى ما يعرف بالمرحله الثالثه
من هذه الحرب وهي المرحله التي يكون فيها
القال اقل كثافه وسيجري فيها مداهمات
وعمليات محدوده ومحدده الاهداف وفقا ل ما
ي ما يستدعيه الوضع وفقا لتصريحات وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي افغل يوم امس وكذلك هذا
جاء على لسان الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي
لكن في هذه الاثناء تسمع في هذه المناطق
اصوات اشتباكات بالرشاشات الثقيله اضافه
الى اصوات التفجيرات التي لا تتوقف طيله
الوقت هناك اصوات انفجارات ناجمه بالمعظمة
ل الاصوات ايضا تسمع من جهه الشرق الاحياء
الشرقيه الشماليه في قطاع غزه وهو ما
يتحدث عنه الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي
بانها عمليات تدمير لما يصفه بالبنى
التحتيه التابعه
لحركات المقاومه لكن في كثير من مقاطع
الفيديو التي ينشرها الجنود بانفسهم من
داخل قطاع غزه نرى بانهم يقومون بعمليات
تفجير واسعه لمبان ومنشات ومقار وابراج
سكنيه لم تتدمر كليا خلال عمليات القصف من
الجو ومن البر هذا اليوم تحدث الناطق
العسكري في بيانه الصباحي بان العمليات في
منطقه خان يونس تتوسع وتتعمق وهو ايضا ما
تحدث عنه المسؤولون السياسيون في الايام
الاخيره الماضيه انه بالرغم من ان هذه
العمليات ستقل كثافتها في المناطق
الشماليه الا انها ستتوسع
وستت في المناطق الوسطى والمناطق الجنوبيه
الى حين احراز الاهداف التي يريدها الجيش
الاسرائيلي ونعيد ونؤكد وهذا اليوم ايضا
ما جاء في مقال لاحد ابرز الكتاب
والمحللين العسكريين في صحيفه دعو احرونوت
الذي كتب مجددا انه عندما يتحدث الجيش عن
احراز اهداف ويحقق انجازات فانها عمليا
انجازات تكتيكيه وليست انجازات استراتيجيه